I am in a weird hotel room there's a
bathtub in the hotel room this is the
Columbia Gorge it is a big beautiful
river that divides the state of
Washington from the state of Oregon a
couple years ago this Columbia Gorge
looked like this some kid threw a
firework into a bunch of brush and it
lit the entire forest on fire 50,000
acres were burned a bunch of people lost
their houses as we're talking about this
luscious pristine green Gorge now
turning orange and red I grew up in
Oregon and this Gorge has always been
like the most beautiful place to go on
hikes and stuff so when I saw the news
that this was burning when I saw this
imagery I was bummed and like look at
this amazing place and it's completely
destroyed by fire
turns out that's wrong that whole idea
that like this fire is destroying this
forest is totally wrong and I recently
learned that it recently delved into
wildfires and discovered an entirely
different narrative about wildfires and
I want to share that with you I want to
do this as quickly as it possibly can so
I'm gonna force myself to make this the
most concise and straight to the point
explainer I've ever made I'm gonna give
myself seven minutes to explain this to
you can I do an adequate explanation in
just a few minutes I think let's find
out okay so first things first what
we're talking about here is not
necessarily all the forest fires or
wildfires in the world but not going
about like the Amazon which is being
burned for deforestation for industry
we're talking about the wildfires in the
western United States which if you live
in the United States you've probably
seen this somewhere on the news it's
hard to wrap your head around this
tonight in the West wicked wildfires
burning their way into the record books
to a record-setting monster now the
largest wildfire in state history the
news likes to think of these wildfires
as a record-breaking or unprecedented
that word or record-breaking or
unprecedented is actually totally wrong
it's important to note that wildfires
used to burn way more land than they do
now okay so this idea that wildfires are
somehow unprecedented or record-breaking
is just wrong factually and here's why
it turns out wildfires are completely
natural sorry let me go a bit further
here wildfires are completely natural
and actually very ecologically
beneficial for a forest ecosystem how am
i doing on time okay so next look at
this beautiful drone image look at this
forest the force of Oregon are beautiful
they blanket entire swaths of land as
far as the eye can see a forest like
this is like a city it has shrubs and
wildflowers and owls and mushrooms and
woodpeckers and random birds that you've
never heard of and all of these
different inhabitants of the city do
different jobs
have different functions they're good at
different things of different
specializations and they all get paid
differently in the sense of sunlight or
nutrients they're all kind of competing
with each other but at the same time
they're kind of working together in a
symbiotic relationship much like a city
everyone there is competing in some ways
but they're also working together the
forest is kind of similar now look at
these trees
these big beautiful evergreen conifer
trees after a while of a forest
development these trees start to get
really tall and they start to hog all of
the sunlight they start to cast a shadow
over the entire forest floor which for
me is just really pretty like hiking
through that it's like really nice but
for the economy of the forest this is
actually not a very good thing it's kind
of like if in a city you just had a few
bigwigs who made all the money had all
the wealth can kind of control all the
land and in those cases everyone suffers
so you're looking at this beautiful
blanket of trees over the mountains and
you're like this is beautiful
this actually isn't the optimal
situation for a forest this is where
fire fire comes in and it resets some of
this it thins out some of the shadow
causing trees it'll burn down some trees
it will leave other trees kind of
untouched it will burn down kind of all
of the underbrush and the understory of
the forest floor let me explain why
business is such a good thing I actually
went back into the gorge
after this burn just a few weeks ago
[Music]
as I was walking through this forest I
was surprised that like not everything
was burned some of these trees just had
a little blackening on their face so
something was really burned up but other
stuff was just fine what happens after a
forest burns is that it begins to regrow
but it begins to regrow very differently
than it was before look at this tree
this is called a snag this is a tree
that was completely burned down the
first thing that happens is that around
the base of this tree you're gonna have
a bunch of new wildflowers and fungi and
plants that couldn't grow there before
because there wasn't sunlight because it
was in shadow now they can grow in the
tree itself you're gonna have a lot of
insects and bugs that now can live
inside of the cavity of this tree
because it's dead it's now becoming more
Hollow then let's say a woodpecker
swoops and starts to eat those bugs and
in the process of pecking on this dead
tree the snag they hollow out a big hole
in this tree then a mammal maybe can
come into this ecosystem and find the
hollow in this tree made by the
woodpecker a great habitat a great home
where they can live suddenly this snag
this totally burned down tree is
actually now an amazing neighborhood in
the forest city the neighborhood has
affordable housing it has amazing new
restaurants and it has a diversity of
different inhabitants that all come
together and share their different
specializations and their benefits for
the benefit of all the reason why this
is such a good thing is because the
currency of a forest is diversity
biodiversity an ecosystem that has lots
of different plants and animals that all
do different things is a more resilient
more thriving ecosystem I mean my
intuition would have said that the
healthiest forests in the world look
like this
but it turns out the healthiest force in
the world look like this forest experts
will call this kind of patchy er look a
mosaic
it's then the poorest now above abandons
green in a mosaic it is a patchwork of
different Ecology's different ecosystems
different habitats that are all tied
together that are all close together and
they create a much more robust ecosystem
and so it turns out that fire is
actually the factor that causes these
more mosaic type forests these more bio
diverse thriving forest systems okay I
don't have very much time left but let
me just finish this up by saying I'm
sitting here talking about all the
benefits of a wildfire but clearly
wildfires can be a disaster
[Music]
they're just not a disaster for the
forest they're a disaster for humans
it's important to note this because
wildfires have become a disaster become
this unprecedented problem because
humans are often affected so fires are
increasing
they're becoming exacerbated by a
warming planet that is a fact both human
caused and naturally caused fires are
doing more damage to humans than ever
but just to remember next time you see
this news of a fire sweeping across some
place that is destroying so much that
fires are a catastrophe for humans but
not necessarily catastrophe for mother
nature or for forests and in fact
they're actually a major benefit I want
to thank Skillshare for sponsoring this
video
funeral Skillshare is it is an online
repository of thousands of tutorials
video based tutorials where you can
learn tons of different things from
entrepreneurship to film to photography
to design really it's all there on
Skillshare there's one course in
particular that's taught by Jake
Bartlett called
the beginner's guide to After Effects
which is a really good overview of a
bunch of different really important
aspects of this software that I used to
do all my animation having a
foundational education in After Effects
can unlock so many features that are
just kind of hidden and not really
intuitive defined Skillshare is a
subscription-based thing so you can go
on subscribe and get unlimited access to
all of these tutorials and kind of learn
whatever you want at your own pace it's
pretty darn cheap it's like under 10
bucks a month if you do the annual
subscription but because they're
sponsoring this video they're giving you
two months free if you're interested you
can go to the link in my description
Center for skill share and start
learning stuff for two months for free
you can see if it's a good fit and then
after that it's literally under ten
dollars I pay more than that for like a
sandwich these days in the city
kind of a shame but seriously I'm a huge
fan of online learning that's how I
learned all of my video and animation
skills is on the internet not through a
school and so I believe in Skillshare
and what they're doing and believe that
you can really learn a lot of stuff with
the internet so go to link in the
description try it out for a couple of
months see how it fits
and thank you Skillshare for sponsoring
this video and thank you for watching
I'm gonna go take a bath I think I'm
still undecided it's kind of a weird
thing to take a bath in a room but it's
also kind of cool I don't know I'll tell
you later how it went okay see ya
[Music]